my wife and I we adjourn to another room
and we don't talk about the nuts and
bolts in front of the kids
no point in contaminating them with fear
and so we we we we want them to be kids
and enjoy their lives and enjoy their
day and that's it whatever the home is
those people need to adjourn privately
and talk in a way that maybe they never
have done before at the same time I mean
kids are smart and they pick up more
than you think they're and they're
constantly talking about what the Koroma
know what's this corona but it's
interesting because they're not stressed
about it as long as we know what Alec is
saying as long as we don't show that
we're stressed out about it um then they
don't get stressed out about and right
now our kids we spend all of our time
together and they are really loving that
so it's interesting to try to get into
their eyes and what do you do you tell
them yeah okay there is a coronavirus
you say yeah there's a virus right now
and mommy and daddy you're doing
absolutely everything to make sure that
we're okay and that's why we're living
differently that's what we're not having
play dates we're not going out we're not
doing this we're not doing that and it's
gonna be like this for a while but it's
because we know that we're gonna be okay
and I try to take advantage the
situation so I'll say to Carmen oh say
Carmen if I ask mommy to make zucchini
bread she might not make it for me but
if you tell her you want zucchini bread
she'll make any bread to get through the
box very impressed with the two of you
because I know my mother would have told
me it was hopeless and we're all gonna
die shaking my mother would have made it
all about her she would not take notice
attention to me at all like you guys I
look at you guys I'm so blown away by
how you care about your kids think my
father would never have explained
anything my mother would have said and I
said there's a coronavirus go up to your
room and just state it don't be a dude
it's the sister and don't bother anybody
so that we don't get aggravated
everything you know you were always in
the service of your parents you were not
a child you know my my my father would
have been watching the news all day even
though there was
no CNN back then but they might have had
like the special reports in the old days
of the REA my mother would have been in
her bed on the phone talking to her
friends saying the same thing like 35
times a day and if we came in to talk to
her even just to us wage our fears my
mother would be like get out I'm on the
phone the virus Jesus the virus you know
and she wouldn't we will all be like we
set the house on fire so you're like
close the door month um
you